les élèves participent ce matin à une
cérémonie de purification ils n'ont que
trois et quatre ans mais déjà ils
apprennent à vivre ce rituel sacré en
langue Wallace
la plus jeune élève de la classe est
mimi guiss sa mère veut que son
immersion commence dès maintenant les
parents et les bébés sont les bienvenus
moi aussi alors on va apprendre ensemble
[Musique]
des années viennent régulièrement en
classe transmettre la langue et la
culture aux petits la présence de Maggie
Paul est précieuse
des rares qui parlent encore couramment
le Wallace Togo maggie est émerveillée
par l'apprentissage rapide des enfants
des fois on voudrait pleurer de joie
parce qu'ils comprennent ils comprennent
fait tout ce qu'elle peut avec les
enfants pour que les mots leur viennent
facilement et le patiente et déterminé
on n'a pas appris la langue à la maison
ça me rend très émotive parce que c'est
qui nous sommes et d'où nous venons
parce qu'elle a adulte et la suivi un
cours universitaire intensif tu es
grosse
cette école m'a apporté beaucoup de joie
et la guérison explique la directrice
guérison parce qu'on a refusé de lui
enseigner le wallastocway enfant la
langue n'était pas valorisée l'anglais
l'était
Lisa producteur a elle aussi suivi un
cours universitaire pour apprendre sa
langue
puis et la décider d'ouvrir cette école
d'immersion pour sauver le Wallace
Subway
avec son équipe elle trouve du
financement qu'on soit des livres
prépare la matière pour les prochaines
années l'objectif est d'avoir 10 élèves
par niveau jusqu'à la 5e année l'école
gaggimine est située dans des locaux
loués à la ville de Frédéric Town
éventuellement elle va déménager dans
cette maison qu'il faut d'abord rénover
est un allié de taille de Lisa c'est son
fils il a remporté un Juneau et un
Polaris pour son premier album qui
fusionne la musique classique et de
vieux chants en Wallace
[Musique]
pendant ces spectacles il invite sa mère
sur scène il fait la promotion de
l'école il mène une campagne de
financement
ça me touche profondément qu'il a une si
grande passion pour notre culture et
notre langue
c'est le moins que je puisse faire pour
cette cause merveilleuse
[Musique]
tous reconnaissent que la tâche est
immense mais le rêve les tout autant ici
Michel Bridou Radio-Canada Frédéric